bonsoir à christopher mesnooh merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
rt france vous êtes avocat au barreau de
new york vous connaissez donc
parfaitement la politique américaine
quel est votre sentiment avec cette
investiture particulière aujourd'hui
très peu de monde pandémique coronavirus
oblige
donald trump qui est absent de cette
cérémonie d'investiture et qui vient
d'arriver du côté de la floride c'est
une cérémonie d'investiture qui restera
dans les annales oui en effet alors
effectivement c'est la suite de l'année
2001 qui a déjà été une année assez
inédite
l'élection au mois de novembre a été
aussi inédite
non pas pour son résultat proprement dit
mais pour les remis ce temps on se fait
à l'ancien président on trempe en
novembre décembre janvier
l'absence du président aujourd'hui à
cette cérémonie d'investiture et
l'absence et pour moi c'est le plus
grave de tout ce que je vois l'absence
en grand nombre du public américain
démocratie ça signifie le gouvernement
pour le peuple et par le peuple est
aujourd'hui malheureusement pour
l'instant le peuple américain qu'on
aurait dû voir pour h&m est largement
absents présence en revanche un
d'anciens présidents les couples obama
george deubeuliou bouche ou encore king
tonnes sont présents on a vu mike pence
également et quel bilan vous faites du
mandat de donald trump écouter
abstraction faite de on va dire ces
douze derniers mois et cette pandémie
qui a créé une crise économique majeure
partout dans le monde
monsieur trempe a tenu certaines de ses
promesses
alors tout le monde n'était pas d'accord
avec ses promesses notamment en matière
d'immigration
en revanche le bilan économique a
incontestablement a été globalement
positive pendant les trois premières
années du mandat de monsieur trompe et
sans le covit il ya des chances qu'il
aurait été réélu le problème se trompe
en quittant la présidence de dans la
manière dont il a quitté la présidence
il a largement effacé quelques victoires
incontestables
il valait si franchement il s'est grillé
et l'image de 34 surtout celles qui
laisse derrière lui
aujourd'hui de notre homme qui à
atterrir du côté de la floride
seul on voit dans quel état d'esprit il
est en colère que le monsieur nous tous
donc il est rancunier il reste convaincu
qu'il a bien gagné ces élections et que
de ce fait se coller en train de
regarder ensemble est quelque chose de
justifier après on connaît aussi qu'il
est incapable de se souvenir qui
l'attend est une soixantaine de recours
devant la justice américaine et les a
tous perdus
il a fait appel aux grands électeurs de
modifier les résultats de l'élection
dans certains états en fait il a perdu
tous les veaux cour que le droit
américain doug abbey dawn est donc
aujourd'hui il est amer il est rancunier
évidemment très très mécontents mais les
états unis c'est un pays qui bouge très
vite et tout ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
va être remplacé j'espère par des choses
très positives de la nouvelle
administration et quant à monsieur
trempe il se trouvera à notre rôle qui
reste à définir
vous parlez de la nouvelle
administration voit des images de joe
biden qui tient donc son premier
discours en tant que président des états
unis 46e du nom joe biden qui salue je
cite une journée 10 poiret la démocratie
l'a emporté
joe biden qui jure je cite de vaincre le
suprématisme blanc et le terrorisme
intérieur
il appelle donc l'america à l'unité
comment est-ce que vous accueillez ce
premier discours joe biden monsieur le
baril gueule et lui même sont tristes
dans la grande tradition du parti
démocrate
il existe également une gauche du parti
démocrate qui à langnau a longtemps
milité pour les droits civiques
d'égalité homme femme
noir blanc et cetera etc le speech de
monsieur byden aujourd'hui et les
premiers actes qui va faire il va être
obligé de habiterait entre sa propre
tradition de son triste et la gauche du
parti démocrate
qui est très très visible très active et
très très très demandeuse de vraies
réformes dont la vie américaine
donc pour m'avoir monsieur bart hayden
comment il va naviguer en eaux très très
trouble christopher mesnooh
restez avec nous puisque je vous propose
de regarder un sujet concernant les dix
sept décrets présidentiels que s'apprête
à signer un joe biden pour tourner le
chapitre donald trump s'employer à
défaire les mesures prises par son
prédécesseur selon mme godin avec médias
ce qui fit le 7 juillet dernier le
président donald trump a retiré les
états unis de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé oms qui l'accusé d'avoir mal
géré la pandémie de coronavirus
l'immunologue anthony fauci va
intervenir comme représentant des états
unis à une réunion du conseil exécutif
de l'om sd ce jeudi le démocrate qui a
fait de la lutte contre le changement
climatique une autre priorité de son
mandat adressera dès ce mercredi un
courrier à l'onu afin que les etats unis
puissent réintégrer la corde paris d'ici
un mois
les etats unis s'étaient retirés de cet
accord seulement quelques mois après
l'investiture de donald trump joe biden
va signé une proclamation pour arrêter
la construction d'un mur à la frontière
avec le mexique engagé par donald trump
et son financement
par ailleurs il va annuler un décret
migratoire controversée adoptée par son
prédécesseur pour interdire aux
ressortissants de pays en majorité
musulman d'entrée aux états unis
joe biden va signer un décret pour
ordonner aux agences fédérales d'évaluer
les inégalités raciales dans leurs
programmes comme leur politique et pour
réinstaurer les formations à la
diversité supprimées par son
prédécesseur avec christopher mesnooh on
vient de voir ce sujet donc de mehdi est
ce qui est fier au sujet des dix sept
décrets de joe biden pour tourner la
page de donald trump réintégrer le ms
l'accord de paris sur le climat
suspendre les travaux également du mur
frontalier avec le mexique comment
est-ce qu'il faut interpréter tout cela
est ce que c'est une provocation de la
part de joe biden vis-à-vis de donald
trump et de sa mandature
je ne pense pas monsieur parisienne
viennent d'une autre tradition politique
aux etats unis
c'est pas le même que monsieur trompe je
trempe a été très idéologique dans sa
manière de gouverner le pays
mais rappelons nous quand même que
monsieur 30 lui-même a essayé de défaire
beaucoup des choses qui ont été réalisés
à l'administration de barack obama
notamment en matière de systèmes de
santé qu'on connaît qui s'appelle
obamacare donc chaque président pour
marquer le début de son administration
et c'est de défaire certaines des actes
son prédécesseur tout ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui
alors c'est normal alors après les 74
millions de personnes qui ont voté pour
trempe
comment ils vont interpréter ces
différents décrets présidentiels qui
sont en train d'être émis par exemple
sur l'immigration qui est un sujet qui
était le sujet clef du président 30
joe biden le président balle elle est en
train de passer un tout autre message
je ne sais pas par provocation en
revanche le magnet l'on sait capter par
le public trompe que effectivement
interprété ça comme une provocation
reste à voir
christopher mesnooh pour l'instant tout
se passe bien au niveau de cette
cérémonie d'investiture c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de soldats de la garde
nationale qui ont été déployés 25000 à
exactement du côté de washington après
les derniers événements du 6 janvier
dernier
les incidents du côté du capitole après
ce qu'il faut s'attendre au niveau de la
tenue de
de cette cérémonie et
elle ne sera pas perturbé selon vous
écoutez comme je dis tout à l'heure pour
moi le corps d'absence visuellement
regardons vos images c'est le peuple
américain et ça ça me trouble après il
ya quelque chose qui me rassure
indépendamment de l'absence du peuple
américain
les autres images qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est les mêmes images 3 tous les quatre
ans c'est à dire il y à une continuité
de la vie politique américaine
défini par la constitution américaine et
respecterait pas quand même une majorité
d'américains et des deux partis
politiques républicains et démocrates
donc je trouve au final plus rassurés
par ce que je vois que troubler il y
compris l'armée d'ailleurs ils ont
d'autres contextes et d'autres pays ont
ils pu essayer ou bien de soutenir le
président sortant ou bien de saisir le
pouvoir
vous voyez bien aux états unis l'armée
et le militaires américains sont très
respectueux de la tradition politique
moi je suis globalement rassurés par ce
que je vois on vient de voir également à
l'instant un bernie sanders qui est
présent aussi pour cette cérémonie
d'investiture
joe biden qui continue de parler qui
évoquer forcément dans ces prochains
jours un des grands chantiers
d'administration balden rester avec nous
un christopher mesnooh pour parler de la
politique étrangère américaine
christopher mesnooh
la politique étrangère de données de joe
biden après la politique étrangère de
jeu de donald trump à quoi est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre exactement
on se souvient de l'unilatéralisme soit
donald trump place maintenant au
multilatéralisme c'est ça écoutez on va
revenir à politique étrangère américain
qui va être très reconnaissable au reste
du monde et notamment aux européens
n'oublions pas non plus que monsieur
blinken le nouveau secrétaire d'état est
parfaitement francophone a passé une
grande partie de sa jeunesse en france
ce qui n'était absolument pas le cas de
l'administration trempe qui était
beaucoup plus orienté sur les états unis
avec presque de là un côté hostilité au
reste du monde
alors il reste des dossiers chauds comme
votre correspondant à 10 diront
notamment la paix au moyen orient entre
israël et notamment les palestiniens
n'oublions pas en revanche que le
président entrant pas pris certaines
décisions qui sont peut-être
irréversible je pense notamment aux
déplacements de l'ambassade américaine
de tel aviv à jérusalem
je pense qu'il ya très très peu de
chances que le président baden renverse
ou à ces deux vins retour atteint le vif
sur cette question donc il y as décision
que tu rends pas prise qui vont perdurer
dans le temps parce que on peut pas du
jour au lendemain
redistribuer les cartes sur la plan sur
le plan stratégique et internationale
néanmoins le pays sera beaucoup plus
ouvert aux autres pays et notamment
beaucoup plus à l'écouté de ce que
pensent les autres trempe à lui la
tendance d'être très renfermé et de
refuser de prendre en considération les
points de vue des autres pays
et ça pour moi c'est fini avec la
nouvelle administration
merci christophe armes mais sont restés
avec nous sur la politique étrangère
de joe biden beaucoup de dossiers
l'attendent la chine donc l'iran
également par exemple on sait que hassan
rohani et
s'est félicitée du départ de donald
trump notamment aujourd'hui écoutés il y
avait justement ce dossier rania un
mouvement dramatique entre
l'administration de barack obama qui a
effectivement participé activement à
l'accord nucléaire avec l'iran
l'administration trempe qui a changé
toute la donne vis à vis de liant en se
retirant de l'accord et de ses
engagements réciproques et maintenant
avec joe biden logiquement on va se
retrouver moins hostile à l'iran ce qui
signifie pas pour autant que les deux
pays vont devenir de meilleurs amis du
jour au lendemain mais il y aura
certainement un peu moins de hostilité
de la part des états unis envers l'iran
est ce que c'est une bonne chose est ce
que c'est une mauvaise chose
le ton du mantra sur les autres dossiers
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure il ya
effectivement également la corée du nord
le moyen orient le commerce et les
stratégies avec la chine
il y avait énormément de dossiers et
monsieur bart hayden et son secrétaire
d'état vont être tentés de faire des
changements radicaux et rapide un
certain des dossiers tandis que sur
d'autres dossiers ils vont être plus
liés par ce qu'on peut appeler leurs
huiles politique c'est à dire on peut
pas changer du jour au lendemain des
relations politiques économiques et
commerciales
donc on va voir mais il y aurait
effectivement un changement de temps et
un changement de fond sur beaucoup de
dossiers très chauds sur le scène
internationale merci christopher mesnooh
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes avocat
au barreau de paris et au barreau de new
york